Hello.
My name is Natalie Villalobos and I'm so excited today to bring out a Amy
Schumer and Aidy Bryant.
They are two incredible women that I am so incredibly inspired by and empowered
by a,
so let's go ahead and bring them on out.
[inaudible]
the Google plants.
Hi Guys.
Oh,
cool.
Amuse is fine.
This is where the counting crows counted or,
thank you for having us guys.
Yes.
All right,
so to kick us off,
you too,
you're in a new film together called I feel pretty.
Tell us what interested you in signing onto this project.
Money.
Money,
money,
money.
Money.
Wow.
Oh,
you guys hate money at Google?
I'm sorry.
Coaching,
coaching,
coaching.
No.
Um,
I was supposed to do this other movie where I would have gotten like a lot,
a lot of that on me,
but it wasn't going to really work out because,
but this is the exact message that I've been wanting to say.
Like,
no,
I didn't want this to just be part of the movie.
I was like,
I really want to hammer this exact message home.
And so like,
you know,
I'm kind of like a [inaudible] when it comes to like,
if my manager sends me a script,
I'll go like,
do you want me to do this?
Do you want me to play a reindeer?
You know?
And,
um,
has that happened?
Like ish?
Yeah.
And so they were like,
hey,
we think this is worth mentioning.
It's,
and they told me the premise and I was like,
that's awesome.
And,
uh,
and then I read the script.
I was like,
this is so funny.
She's giving you lovey eyes.
I know she wants it.
Are you lower?
Like I'm low.
Why am I so high?
We just did.
We did one this morning
at either one of you.
And,
um,
and we got there and they kept saying to me like 80,
you'll be in the middle chair.
Okay.
Just remember 80 year in the middle of the chair to the middle of,
of these things.
I really over explain it.
And they go like,
breathe,
you bend your knees to sit.
Okay.
And then we got out there and we sat down and mine was like a little toad
Stewart.
It was like I was literally on the ground,
like in a basket
and Amy and the moderator and we're like seated high.
It was very humbling and I'm proud to be lower now.
Yeah.
If you want,
we can switch roles at some point and you could be the moderator.
There's nothing that could get me to get into one of these seats again.
Sorry about that.
That's why I'm like kind of doing the one leg.
I know.
This is
great.
I love,
I'm so scared that I'm going to show my full Gucci said like all y'all.
So we'll just strategically placed the plants.
Yeah.
So with the film,
did you have any creative control over your characters?
Sounds like you,
the script was there,
you signed on and at any point did you ad Lib or change the original direction
of a character you're naughty?
Um,
yeah,
I'm a producer of this movie and uh,
it's,
it's cool.
I've gotten myself into a position where I don't have to,
did I don't want to.
And uh,
so I helped rewrite it and we were super collaborative and uh,
yeah.
And we lived a little bit.
Yeah.
Unfortunately I only had to say things I didn't want to.
This was a bad experience for me and it sucks to be here.
I'm sorry.
And you know,
I,
I know we're all supposed to be like lifting up other women in this business,
but I just wanted to push her down.
So you were like,
wrote it into her contract.
Only give her bad little yeah,
yeah,
no,
I'm,
we improvised a lot
because we always,
we've like one brain like all the time will always say the same words.
So,
um,
so in the film,
so I got,
I got a chance to sneak peek,
watch it on Friday night and it was awesome.
Thank you.
Yeah.
It's like hold for a compliment.
You know when people are like,
I saw the show this week and then you go,
Ooh,
okay.
No,
I really loved it.
Um,
so one of the,
my favorite parts was actually when your character,
Renee was taking some web traffic reports to her company.
There was a mantra she had to say,
I am brave,
I am blind and I got this.
So what body positive mantra would you give to women of the world?
Okay,
well first of all,
Adrian Martinez,
who I've worked with a bunch,
he improvised that line and uh,
he just kind of went nuts and he's giving me this pep talk and it made it into
the movie.
So God bless him.
Don't be fooled by the illusion of a quality.
We've all been sold.
I don't know to tell you Google.
That's why she's on a high stool.
That was perfect.
I mean,
we got it to work for it.
Question at all.
So they're like,
yeah,
well we weren't impressed with what she said,
so that makes sense.
How about you?
Yeah,
your mantra bitch.
Like,
just stay on the stool.
Just use the chair.
You can grab on to Amy Jo j
I'm in
a bad situation.
We had an interview and I'm legitimately scared.
We had an interview this morning,
kind of over
a question like that where they were like,
um,
if like,
I'm not afraid.
So I am like,
you know,
I was looking for us to say something inspirational and an 80.
That's just like,
I'm scared of birds and we're like,
no,
that's not,
I am though.
I'm scared of deviled eggs.
Yeah,
I know.
I'm scared of crazy bitches.
Okay.
You,
you guys,
you guys deviled eggs burger.
So good.
I almost just got those at lunch.
No,
no,
that's Facebook.
It's okay.
Okay.
So speaking of leaning in a little bit,
I feel like there's some sh some shamelessness in the movie.
Like what would you say in one word,
what is that
confidence that she had?
Like,
you know,
we got this backlash,
which was really funny because first of all,
very flattering people were like,
you're not discussing enough to be in that.
And I was like,
oh,
I'm like,
am I supposed to what?
She said not to know Gus.
Yeah.
They were like,
you don't have any right?
Like we the to feel bad about yourself and it's not this a story of like a very
homely,
awful woman who finds confidence.
It's just somebody who struggles with self esteem,
which everyone does,
you know,
and she feels very invisible.
And,
um,
and then goes through this whole experience where she realizes like,
where your confidence really should come from and what's actually sustainable,
which is not your looks.
Um,
but so we got this like crazy backlash and uh,
and it was,
it was Kinda,
it was funny,
you know?
Um,
I don't remember.
I don't remember at all what I'm talking about.
No,
I was,
I was just thinking too,
like I,
I was also getting messages that were like,
come on,
like how could they have Amy Schumer do this role when they have a plus size
woman right there.
She could have done the role and it's like,
oh,
okay,
so you're saying I'm out of the norm enough that I should play the troll?
Or like,
what,
what are we fighting about this for?
You know,
like,
I feel like it really muddles the issue that is like,
you know,
Amy and I both,
whether you like it or not,
like are not the norm in movies.
You know,
like 99% of movies,
nobody looks like me or Amy and we good.
Yeah,
no,
but
I guess
to me it's like,
it's almost like a snake eating its own tail where it's like,
well how,
how,
what do I have to be?
Or what does Amy have to be too?
Like this is a story that is about self confidence,
which truly is like,
it's all in here.
It's not out here.
And that is what is all damn about.
It's all damn about.
And,
and we have talked about this where like we both feel good in
our skin and,
um,
on the stool,
I mean,
this is this,
this is a special scenario thinking me back down to like,
I'm 13 years old.
No,
this is about them and for you,
this is your bottom.
But,
um,
but we realize like you really,
it's not about us feeling good about ourselves.
It's like we have to literally comfort other people about our bodies.
Like they're like,
so you just like go out and until like the store in the morning and you're just
spin your body and you're like,
yeah,
and I'm,
I'm happy.
And they're like,
can you walk me through that?
And you're like,
no,
I don't think I can.
But,
so it's literally us like explaining to other people,
making them comfortable.
Um,
but you know,
there's nothing scarier or more upsetting to people then a woman who feels good
about herself.
Like people really hate that.
Uh,
yeah.
So,
so they're like,
okay,
well,
like how can I find an angle where you're unhappy?
So like I can sleep at night and you're like,
yeah,
of course.
Like I,
we have struggles like everyone else.
But then also we want to say if I were a person of color hearing this
conversation,
I'd be like,
is it hard for you guys?
You know?
And I,
I hear you and I,
uh,
we both really want to do our part and make sure that our work is super
inclusive and,
um,
you know,
not just for people of Color,
but trans people,
people with disabilities,
like,
you know,
cause what we're learning is that the leaders being all white men for so long
is,
is not actually that great for everybody.
And,
uh,
we need women.
Like,
if you think of it,
women aren't even on,
on many boards.
Like,
it's to get like one woman,
two women in there.
And by the way,
you have to see the Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
Maybe can,
we just don't want to him.
But you know,
it's because like the things I gravitate toward are,
are women.
People are getting,
you know,
so if I was at the person making the decisions and Samantha Bee did that awesome
piece this week about how like one in 10 women has endometriosis,
but there's like very little research but there's like a thousand Dick Pills,
you know?
No,
I've actually,
I've actually recently started telling people in my meetings when I'm having
intense cramps.
So it's like I'm just being going to be very real with the fact that I'm just
like in pain anymore.
No,
I know.
But if we do
not got a problem deal,
oh,
that's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
That's exactly what I said.
And I do have a problem.
Right?
Yeah.
You do your edit.
So you had mentioned,
um,
we can sit with it a little bit more.
I'm tempted to just stay.
This will be like,
I can't tell you the relief I feel right now.
And so I'll up here like an asshole.
No,
no,
no.
Look,
I'm going to just stand in a spot where my store was.
So,
uh,
I'm going to,
I'm sorry we can all stand.
so when I was 10,
um,
my mom would tell me,
oh,
Natalie,
don't worry,
your,
your boobs will grow in,
which I'm still waiting for.
But you know,
I used to wear a water bra and so it was like a bra for those of you that don't
know water bras abroad with two big sacks of water.
And it basically made me go from like a double a to a c and I'd walk around
really confidently as a sophomore.
And I was really just like moved of like,
okay,
so I have to change how I present myself based on how my mom or how other women
perceive me.
And so I'm curious,
how have other people's perceptions shaped who you are today or
perceptions of yourself?
Well,
first of all,
thank you for trusting us.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It was honorable moment.
No,
totally.
I mean,
I used to wear like very padded bras.
I'm like to a point where it was just like,
it was somebody should have just like sued me when they were hooked up with me.
Like,
this is not at all what I entered the contract or um,
I got,
uh,
but you know that,
but that company,
it's not your got to your mom and they like you,
you know all the marketing and you got to look like this one person.
And if you cover all the heads and the gossip magazines across the row,
everyone has the same body and you're told like if you don't look like this one
thing,
then you're wrong.
And then you realize like,
no,
and what does,
what does it about?
And other than it really is about how you feel about yourself.
And we know that,
right?
That's easy to say.
But the way that you want your friends to see themselves,
like your best friends who were like,
Nah,
and you're like,
you're so pretty.
You know,
sometimes you can like cover their head and a picture and be like,
what if you saw this girl walked by?
Wouldn't you be like,
that's a beautiful girl.
And they're like,
oh yeah.
Um,
but I think other than the media,
it's like,
I think mothers need to know,
um,
how much their message it goes through to their kids.
Yeah.
Because if they're going,
I'm disgusting,
like their daughter's going to be like,
I'm gross.
Um,
my mom did the opposite and was just like,
just made me think I was actually beyond say as a child.
And then you know,
you,
you get older and like stuffed chips away,
your confidence and kids are mean and you kind of like,
or like,
oh,
okay.
Oh,
I'm gross.
I'm discussing.
Okay.
And w this movie is about like trying to get back to that childlike version of
yourself or you feel good and you're not like thinking you need a water bra.
Yeah.
Well,
and I think part of the sisterhood that you were able to offer her in the movie
was like group friendship,
right?
And like supporting someone both through the good and the bad of their body
image.
Right.
And that those perceptions.
So can you tell me a little bit about how important sisterhood is as we,
you know,
kind of look at ourselves,
like tell her about her traveling pants?
Oh,
Amy.
No,
I mean,
honestly for me,
and this is maybe going to sound Corny,
but like for me,
my friends and my like female colleagues who have encouraged me have been my
only way to
success,
you know,
at least for myself.
And like I was so encouraged by,
you know,
performers who I admired early on in Chicago or wherever where like I would have
never continued going without their encouragement.
And even like,
you know,
now I'm like navigating this whole other thing,
which is like how do I exist as a fat woman on TV that's not a mom he character
who's in her forties like whatever,
you know,
that is like,
that's where people are comfortable seeing like my body type.
But I got hired as no one,
I was 24 so those aren't,
those are like,
but so like I'm trying to find my own
place in this system that where there hasn't really been a place for me.
And previously,
and I could not do it without people like Amy or my friends who are like
encouraging me and helping me navigate like all the fricking bolt.
Which is funny because people look like us all over the country.
You know,
it looks like me,
but yes.
Yeah.
70% of American women actually have my body type.
Right.
You know,
but they're not reflected on screen and that's just my,
and we're not skinny shaming either.
Like everybody feels if you're a woman,
like
not and not that men don't feel like
insecure specialty this time.
You're like,
what's our place?
Like can we go to a time's up meeting?
And you're like,
oh,
you guys all hate us now.
But it's not about,
I mean,
yes.
Like,
yes,
thank you.
But what's the weirdest thing you've done for beauty?
For most of my life,
uh,
like wore heels and those kinds of bras and spanx and,
and still felt really mediocre.
That's the weirdest thing I did for beauty just like my whole life every day
until like pretty recently.
Yeah.
The guys in your look like the guys in the movie,
like that's my romantic leads.
So you guys will like this.
Like you guys are definitely like the sweet,
like intelligent look like,
well,
you know,
don't worry.
Okay.
It's like a very gentle,
gentle man.
I'm trying to,
I don't know if I have a like a
weirdest thing I've done for beauty.
I don't know.
I feel,
I feel like just like buying jeans.
So I'm like,
that's a hell.
And Him and every time I do it I'm like,
what is happening?
Last question before we jump to Q.
And.
A,
when that voice inside yourself,
it says you can't do it.
What do you say to that voice?
I think personally I learned along,
I learned like maybe 10 years ago,
I don't even have that voice anymore.
I'm like,
it's other people telling you you can't do it and you,
you just go like,
I'm going,
I'm going to do it.
Wow.
Do you know?
I mean seriously.
It's like
no.
And not giving energy to any of that.
Just like,
no,
I'm going to take the steps,
need to to do it.
I
definitely still have that voice,
but I,
I also feel now,
like I,
I've always been like very bad at like rules or like if someone tells me I have
to do something,
I'm,
I immediately in like,
I guess I'm okay doing that.
Which includes this stool.
You could not have done that on it.
No,
thank you.
This is so nice.
That's nice.
That's cool.
A man.
It's saving you.
Wow.
Just kidding.
Is that funny?
We're still like,
can you open my car door?
Thank you.
You can just hold it.
I will.
Yeah.
I hope they bring out three more chairs.
A little sandbox.
I think we're going to go to Q and a great first question.
Hello ladies.
I'm very happy you're here and I absolutely love your honest Rhonchi feminism.
Um,
I have an eight year old daughter who got invited to her first dress up party
where they're going to give her makeup and hair.
She has to wear a dress and get in a long pink stretch limo.
Wow.
Um,
I'm a hardcore feminist.
My daughter knows this.
I look like this.
Um,
how do I wrap my head around that?
What advice can I give her?
So she still knows she's her.
But Ken go cause all the other girls are going.
That's a great question.
Well I would assume mother's love,
like getting advice from people without children.
MMM.
My instincts,
uh,
as someone who's been fiercely on birth control for a long time,
mmm.
If she likes that stuff then cool.
But if it's not her jam,
like
bless you then like he's out.
Totally.
I mean I keep thinking like,
I dunno,
I feel like especially for what we do,
we have to get dressed and cinched and paint it up all the time.
And there is like a part of it that's like guys show up 10 minutes before and
they would ever,
but like you know,
there's also like a part of that that's self expression that I think,
at least for me back and my legs are outfits.
Like it was fun to learn about that stuff and see how I want it to be.
So I think there's like,
you know,
there's,
there's good in a little bit of all of it,
but like in moderation.
Right.
And like don't get the limo though.
No,
but honestly,
Craig got the Limo,
they got there and kind of corner room for two more.
Thank you.
So first of all,
you both are beautiful.
Um,
80 I love your short squeeze video.
I remember the first time I saw that I was like,
Yo,
this girl's got to be an SNL and then you were so hold I have to tell.
Can I just tell you briefly that that video was something I was paid to do?
What was it?
An advertisement and I,
I believe I was paid $25.
My question is,
so my
younger sister is trying to be a standup comedian in Chicago.
She's actually sort of trying to,
you know,
fall on both of your footsteps.
She's a huge fan of both of yours.
I'm not that funny.
So I don't really have any advice to give her.
But,
um,
every time she calls me on the phone,
she's giving me this whole thing about how hard it is to be a woman in comedy.
And you know,
I was shocked when I saw on Saturday night live to that Tiffany Haddish was I
think the first female standup comic or black female standup comic ever to host
the show.
And I was like 2018 with that was happening.
So what is it going to take to get comedy to a place of more gender and race
diversity?
You know,
just like a small question.
Oh,
well,
first of all,
for her,
like just any comedian I say just to get as much stage time as possible.
Um,
and uh,
in terms of it being harder for a woman,
I just think it's harder for a woman to leave the house in the morning.
Like it's just all harder.
Yeah.
But,
um,
and I think,
you know,
Saturday night live is an example of,
uh,
a very fun,
great show that is run by
white men.
And so that's why we need more leaders to look all different to make sure that
the things like that are more diverse and there's in more equal number of sort
of email or
people of color,
like honestly whatever it is.
And that's,
and that's amazing.
I would just say,
um,
that I,
I also think like when those moments come along when like,
you know,
Tiffany Haddish is hosting SNL to be like calling it out.
I mean like,
damn,
this is the first time a black female standup has ever hosted the show.
Something to think about,
you know,
like the,
I feel like a,
for a long time nobody who was like talking about it openly.
And I think that's part of,
Oh,
I'm sorry,
I just,
Oh,
I'm so sorry.
Fall Asleep.
Oh,
oh,
time's up.
So no,
thank you for calling that out and yes,
you know,
don't be afraid to add to that a little bit.
So it's like you have people who are on stage but also writers to write.
We need more women writers,
people of Color who are writing.
It's like the other roles too that might not be visible,
but that are critical.
And I also think a lot of that is on some of these like,
you know,
comedy clubs and stand up places and,
and you know,
like the theaters in Chicago where you learn and start to do that.
It's like they need to be reaching out and getting these people in positions
where they can also be seen by,
uh,
you know,
people who are coming to scout.
So it's,
it's sort of like,
it's like everybody should we be putting in the work,
you know?
Hi.
Um,
I'm in a comedy sketch,
curb all Asian American women here in town.
So I wanted to ask about your sketch writing process when you have an idea then
how do you get it to a tight place where you know,
I got this winter.
Yeah.
Well if you're,
you had a full sketch show that like one p bodies and is this as a thing?
Don't look at me.
Not about that.
Me.
No,
she's asking you,
you are currently in the sketch universe.
Um,
I,
Gosh,
tough question.
I think it's also like different for every person.
And there's a different ways.
For me at SNL I tried to just like really go off of like what is on my mind that
week because we really do only start writing on Tuesday and the show is on
Saturday.
So you know,
the turnaround is quick and if you have something that you're kind of just like
slowly dumping out,
it's going to be a really long,
hard week.
You know,
like you kind of have to have something that you're like a little bit passionate
about and feels either fun or topical or whatever that like feels important to
you.
And then,
um,
cause the whole week is a little bit of a battle to try and keep it in the show.
So,
um,
you want to feel like,
oh I believe in this.
And then as far as like getting it tight,
I think to me it's just like listening to audiences and being like,
wow,
I really love this part in the middle,
but it played to dead silence and so we're going to cut it out.
And even though it makes our sketch from the was five minutes,
now it's three minutes and 30 seconds.
It's better for it cause it has more impact and it's tighter.
So you know the audience,
lots of,
you know,
like we test,
you test the movie and you're like,
okay,
my favorite joke coming up.
And the audience is just like,
and you can't be like,
no,
you're wrong.
Let me just get up and really quickly explain why that's funny to you.
Like you have to pay attention to that and an edit.
Yeah.
Cool.
Thank you.
What's your group called?
Granny cart.
Gangstas
oh,
so in the movie your character hits her head and gains all this self confidence.
Given that most of us aren't going to get to hit our heads and get that self
confidence,
is there anything that you would suggest as like,
you know,
real world way to get that we'll see this movie?
Yeah.
Like it just,
it takes it,
it's been a process.
You know,
it's like these little false starts where like I feel good about myself maybe
forever now.
And then,
you know,
again,
and um,
that was me getting my period.
Okay.
And I know you guys aren't allowed to get that at Google,
but they're like little gymnast,
but,
um,
but I think,
uh,
I think paying attention to when you feel the best and you know,
it's like when you're with your friends,
you're just laughing and you're,
you're not thinking about what you look like and that's when you're,
when you're not looking in the mirror,
you know,
fixating,
it's like,
and when you find what you really get your confidence from,
and then just hanging onto that and just reminding yourself like,
I'm going to,
I feel good right now.
I'm going to remind myself when I don't that first of all,
I will feel good again.
And this is just a feeling I have right now and it will be replaced by another
feeling.
MMM.
Yeah.
Hashtag.
Yeah,
no,
I agree.
I feel like,
at least for me,
like so often what I go back to is like,
what is my value?
And it's not my body.
It's like my comedy,
my writing,
my mind,
my performance,
my timing.
Like all of those things.
And it's easy to,
to stop hating yourself when you start like going through your list of like,
wait,
why am I valuable to this world?
And like,
you know,
I don't think it's because of my thigh,
like I never have really.
And so even though the world is telling you like your thigh matters,
it,
kindness
does it.
So once you can like start to think about that.
Do you guys want to see my thigh?
No.
Leave them alone.
You already did.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Uh,
I want it to end on a quote I actually saw on Twitter.
It's wrap us up
when you guys are fat
is not that at all.
Tell us the main quotes.
This is that one mine thing happening again.
Oh
No,
I'm above the bridge.
You're hogs.
I'm sorry.
No,
no,
don't worry about it.
I was actually going to say something like,
uh,
some days,
some days you eat salads and go to the gym and some days you eat cupcakes and
refuse to put on your pants.
And it's called balance.
I like the,
the hogs.
Thank you so much.